david shimmer you've never been on the
show before i'm not thanks for
never inviting me oh no that can't be
true that can't be true
no i'm really i'm really but we're very
nice to see you
and here's a weird thing uh you don't
meet many of these people
david schwimmer you are sitting next
door to a unicorn
uh mark ruffalo tell david an
interesting fact about yourself
you know the fact i come from kenosha
wisconsin that's one of them
no you've never seen friends have you ah
i i wish that you seen you must have
seen like
you must have i've seen a lot of parts
of it
it's not no no no no no no it's it's
totally to me
but that must be rare it is it's i think
i'm the i'm probably
i'm the only one okay i've got a mission
to make okay
um when i was sent the uh the script of
episodes
and i read the first uh at the first
episode of episodes and it said
uh and who's gonna be in your show matt
leblanc and i did have to google him
no so yeah i'm so sorry david
there's only one person and then the
rest of the show
was just going to be bigging you up
right nick do you know who he is
sorry which sitcom is this
okay i'm going to get a dvd set too yeah
i appreciate it
the odd thing about one of those
characters and you know ross and friends
one of the things that people keep
asking about going back
but you don't need to because it it's
it's still was it 15 years since you did
the last episode yeah
and it's still on people are still
coming to it
it's like you are still making it
well it must be the other it must be the
weirdest thing yeah it's uh
it's very similar to being a superhero
in some of the biggest movies in the
world um no i'm a fan by the way of all
the movies so
all of them
i'm gonna watch them all tonight yeah
um yeah no i mean it's look it's uh
we're we're both um surprised uh the
whole cast just really surprised and
also overjoyed that the show is still
finding an audience and and younger
generations are
are finding something fun about it but
also you must
meet people who are so young and like
they're watching for the first time
my daughter watches it well that that
you would think that's like a fun
father-daughter activity
but no no it's not yeah
he he got me